hola muy buenos días pues ya han abierto
los colegios electorales y en pocos
minutos espera que vote el presidente
sebastián piñera y como bien decía son
las elecciones más inciertas en chile
porque recordemos que los últimos 16
años el gobierno se ha alternado entre
la centroderecha de sebastián piñera y
la centroizquierda que representa
michelle bachelet y la concertación que
gobernó chile desde el retorno a la
democracia es por primera vez en muchas
décadas que los chilenos no tienen
certeza con seguridad de cuáles son los
candidatos que van a pasar la segunda
vuelta aunque sí habrá una segunda
vuelta hay dos favoritos que marcan las
encuestas la opción de ultraderecha de
jose antonio kast y la de izquierda de
gabriel boric pero estas encuestas son
también criticadas y fallaron
estrepitosamente en las elecciones
anteriores